THOSE CAMPS TO FACTORIES ACROSS
CHINA.
>> Bret: STATE DEPARTMENT,
THANK YOU.
FOR MORE IN CHINA, HONG KONG,
AND AMERICA’S ROLE IN THE WORLD,
JOINING ME NOW IS MIKE POMPEO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THE GO THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON
THIS EVENING.
>> Bret: WE TALKED ABOUT
FORCED LABOR OUT OF THEIR
SUPPLIES CHANGE.
APPEARED AS DESCRIBED BY THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT, WILL WE SEE
INVESTIGATIONS UNDER PROSECUTION
PROSECUTION?
>> IT’S BEEN VERY CLEAR, THE WAY
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE
DEALT WITH THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY BY TURNING THE OTHER CHEEK
IS NOT GOING TO CONTINUE, SO WE
RESPONDED ACROSS A NUMBER OF
FRONTS.
YOU IDENTIFY FORCED LABOR,
NOBODY WANTS TO BUY PRODUCT THAT
WAS MADE WITH SLAVE LABOR.
IF THEY WANT CLARITY ABOUT THE
TRACING OF THE PRODUCT THAT THEY
HAVE.
WE EXPECT EVERY BUSINESS TO
EVALUATE THE SUPPLY CHAIN, MAKE
SURE NOTHING LIKE THAT EVER GETS
IN, WE PUT THEM ON NOTICE FOR
ACTIONS WE MAY TAKE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
>> LAST MONTH HE SAID HE HELD
OFF SANCTIONS CHINESE OFFICIALS
WITH THE MASS DETENTION CAMPS
BECAUSE IT WOULD’VE INTERFERED
WITH THE TRADE DEAL WITH CHINA.
SHOULD THOSE HAVE BEEN
SEPARATED?
>> I’VE BEEN SECRETARY OF STATE
FOR TWO AND HALF YEARS, IT’S
COMPLEX.
IT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR WHEN HE SIGNED THIS BILL
LAST WEEK THAT WE WERE GOING TO
TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY, WE’RE GOING
TO DEAL WITH IT, WE’RE GOING TO
PUT HARSH RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE,
AND WERE WORKING ON THAT.
NO COUNTRY HAS RESPONDED IN THE
SAME WAY THAT WE HAVE.
WE HOPE THE WHOLE WORLD WILL
JOIN.
WHAT’S GOING ON THERE IS
HISTORIC, ITS FORCED
STERILIZATION, FORCING WOMEN TO
HAVE ABORTIONS, THIS IS THE
PLACE WITH SOME OF THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL VIOLATIONS OF HUMAN
RIGHTS THE WORLD IS SEEN IN AN
AWFULLY LONG TIME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN SERIOUS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THE
WORLD SERIES THIS.
WE HOPE IT GOES ACROSS THE WORLD
WORLD.
INCLUDING MUSLIM COUNTRIES TO
PUTTING THEIR SHOULDER TO THE
GRINDSTONE TO HELP RESOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AS WELL.
>> Bret: HE HAD A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES.
>> THERE IS NO COUNTRY THAT HAS
DONE MORE, AND I’M CONFIDENT
WILL DO MORE.
>> Bret: IN HONG KONG, WE DID
A STORY THERE ABOUT THE NEW
SECURITY LAW IN PLACE, YOU’VE
CERTIFIED THAT HONG KONG IS NO
LONGER SUFFICIENTLY AUTONOMOUS.
AGAIN, SHOULD THE ADMINISTRATION
HAVE ACTED MORE FORCEFULLY TO
DETER CHINESE CRACKDOWN IN
HONG KONG?
>> I’LL TELL YOU, I WISH
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS HAD
TAKEN CHINA SERIOUSLY.
THIS IS IN PARTISAN, 40 YEARS OF
FAILED AMERICAN POLICY WITH
RESPECT TO CHINA.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
CLEAN IT UP, TRYING TO GET IT
RIGHT, THE CHINESE HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF US IN MULTIPLE
WAYS.
YOU’VE DONE REALLY GOOD WORK,
IMPORTANT WORK TRYING TO PROTECT
THE FREEDOMS OF PEOPLE.
THEY’VE CHOSEN TO GO A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION, AND WERE RESPONDING
IN A WAY THAT WILL PUT PRESSURE
ON BEIJING, AND TRY TO MAINTAIN
WHATEVER WE CAN OF REMAINING
FREEDOMS IN HONG KONG.
I WILL TELL YOU THE NOTION THAT
REMAINS, ONE COUNTRY TO SYSTEMS
IS FUNDAMENTALLY AT ODDS WITH
THE FACTS ON THE GROUND TODAY.
I REGRET THAT.
>>>> Bret: NOW JOHN BOLTON SAYS
THIS IS ALL ABOUT ELECTION
POLITICS, TO GET CHINA TO BUY
SOYBEANS AND PLACES THAT AFFECT
REELECTION.
ECO-NONSENSE.
>> Bret: OKAY, THAT’S WHAT WE
GET FROM THAT.
WHAT DOES SUCCESS LOOK LIKE WITH
CHINA?
THE U.S. AND CHINA -- WHAT DOES
IT LOOK LIKE?
CAN CHINA BE A RESPONSIBLE
PARTNER WITH THE PRESIDENT AT
THE HOME IN THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY QUESTION MIKE >>
THAT’S UP TO THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY, THAT’S THEIR
DECISION.
WHAT THE UNITED STATES CAN
CONTROL IS WHAT WE DO WHEN
THERE’S UNFAIR AND NONRECIPROCAL
TRADE, WERE GOING TO DEMAND THAT
IT BE RIGHT HERE TO WHEN THEY
DON’T DO IT, WERE GOING TO PLACE
TARIFFS ON THEIR GOODS.
WHEN THEY ENGAGE IN BEHAVIOR
THAT’S MILITARILY THREATENING,
WERE GOING TO PUT A BILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE TO KEEP AMERICA SAFE AND
SECURE.
WHEN CHINESE PARTICIPATE IN
ESPIONAGE, WERE GOING TO PUT
PENALTIES ON THEM.
IF WE ARE HOPEFUL, WE WANT THE
CHINESE PEOPLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL,
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
TODAY HAS MADE A DECISION, IT
WANTS TO BE AN IMPERIALIST
POWER, WANTS TO BE AUTHORITARIAN
IN NATURE, WANTS TO COMPETE
ACROSS THE WORLD IN WHICH THEY
ARE CONSISTENT WITH GOOD THINGS
HAPPENING FOR AMERICAN PEOPLE,
AND DEMOCRACIES ACROSS THE
WORLD.
PRESIDENTS TRUMPS POLICIES ARE
AIMED AT COMBATING THAT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE RUSSIA BOUNTY STORY.
DOES THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT HAVE
AMERICAN BLOOD ON ITS HAND IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
HAS PUT OUT TO STATEMENTS.
I’M GOING TO HONOR WHAT THEY
SAID.
HERE’S WHAT I CAN SAY WITH
ABSOLUTE CERTAINTY.
IF THE UNITED STATES HAS
RESPONDED APPROPRIATELY TO THE
THREAT THAT HAS PRESENTED TO IT
IN AFGHANISTAN CONSISTENTLY.
IT MIGHT THREE AND A HALF YEARS
AS CIA DIRECTOR AND SECRETARY OF
STATE, THERE ARE MANY FOLKS WHO
ARE USING THE TALIBAN OVER YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS AS PROXY
FORCES.
THERE’S BEEN MONEY FUNNELED IN
THERE FROM ALL ACROSS THE WORLD,
UNFORTUNATELY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TAKEN THIS
SERIOUSLY, WE ARE HOPEFUL, WE
MAKE PROGRESS ON HER PIECE AND
RECONCILIATION.
WHETHER IT’S IRANIANS OR
RUSSIAN, WILL MAKE SURE THERE
ARE NO.
THEY’VE BEEN PROVIDING MONEY FOR
THE TALIBAN FOR YEARS, THIS IS
AN ONGOING CHALLENGE.
THEY ARE CHIEFLY AWARE OF THE
THREAT.
>> Bret: YOU JUST REFERENCED
YOU WERE CIA DIRECTOR, THERE’S
OFTEN NOT CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY ON INTEL.
SHOULDN’T THE PRESIDENT HAVE
BEEN TOLD ABOUT IT?
WE KNOW THAT IT WAS DISCUSSED IN
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNSEL, YOU
SAID TODAY KEY MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS HAD THAT INTEL AS WELL,
EVEN THOUGH THERE WASN’T
CONSENSUS.
WHY WAS THE PRESIDENT NOT
BRIEFED ON IT?
>> THAT’S NOT QUITE RIGHT.
MOST INTELLIGENCE -- THERE IS IN
FACT A CONSENSUS.
ALMOST ALL ANALYTICAL PRODUCT
HAS A CONSENSUS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT.
EVERY MORNING I WAKE UP, AND I
READ THE INTELLIGENCE MATERIALS.
WHEN I READ THEM, THERE ARE
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE WORLD WHO
ARE THREATENED, INCLUDING MY
OFFICERS AND EMBASSIES ACROSS
THE WORLD.
WE DON’T ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT
GETS TO THE PRESIDENT, WE DO THE
RIGHT THING.
WE MAKE SURE THE GROUND KNOWS,
THE COMMANDER KNOWS, THE ALLIES
MAY BE THREATENED AS WELL MAKE
SURE THEY KNOW.
TO KEEP OUR SOLDIERS SAFE AND
SECURE, IT’S MOST IMPORTANT.
WHEN THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
FEELS LIKE SOMETHING NEEDS TO
GET TO THE PRESIDENT, THEY WILL
PRESENTED TO HIM.
WHEN I WAS A DIRECTOR, I DID IT.
>> DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
PIECE?
>> I DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE INTEL IN PARTICULAR.
I’M NOT TRYING TO BE CLEVER,
THERE’S JUST SO MUCH THAT IS
BEEN REPORTED THAT IS NOT
ACCURATE AND INCOMPLETE BY
REFUTING ANY PARTICULAR ELEMENT
FOR IT, I’M PUTTING AT RISK OUR
CAPACITY TO RESOLVE AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT’S GOING ON.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE LEAK ITSELF PEERED
HERE’S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE IS SAYING ABOUT IT.
>> HE FORGETS THAT, OR HE
DOESN’T THINK IT’S NECESSARY
THAT HE NEEDS TO KNOW IT.
THEY PICK UP THE PHONE AND SAID,
VLADIMIR, OLD BUDDY, IF ANY OF
THIS IS TRUE, AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT YOU’VE GOT A BIG PROBLEM.
>> Bret: IS NOT JUST
DEMOCRATS, YOU HAVE PEOPLE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR SAYING IT
DEMANDS A SERIOUS RESPONSE, YOU
HAVE TWO KEY REPUBLICANS THE
HOUSE, MIKE McCALLUM SAYING
THEY’RE POLITICIZING THIS ISSUE
AND WE CANNOT LET POLITICS OVER
SHATTERED THE TRUTH.
THE PUTIN REGIME CANNOT BE
TRUSTED.
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE SWIFT AND
SERIOUS ACTION TO HOLD TO THE
REGIME ACCOUNTABLE.
>> THERE’S BEEN NO
ADMINISTRATION TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
I ONLY WISH FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD HELD
THE RUSSIANS ACCOUNTABLE.
WE’VE BEEN CLEANING UP A LOT
LESS OF A MESS.
I WISH WE PROVIDED ARMS TO THE
UKRAINIANS, I WISH HE HADN’T
ALLOWED RUSSIANS INTO SYRIA, I
COULD GO ON, BUT YOU GOT A SHORT
SHOW.
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
ALLOWED THE RUSSIANS A LOT OF
SPACE TO MOVE.
WE SANCTIONED MORE RUSSIANS THAN
ANY OTHER ADMINISTRATION IN
HISTORY.
TAKE A BACKSEAT TO KNOW WHAT TO
EXPECT TO HOLD VLADIMIR
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN HE IS ENGAGED
IN MALIGN ACTIVITY.
A SHOW FIND OUT THERE’S EVIDENCE
THEY’RE PUTTING OUR SOLDIERS AT
RISK ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD,
INCLUDING IN AFGHANISTAN, I’M
VERY CONFIDENT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL DIRECT ME, AND HE AND
HIMSELF WILL RESPOND
APPROPRIATELY.
>> Bret: HOW DAMAGING IS THAT
LEAK?
THEY SAID THERE WERE ROGUE
OFFICERS IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY WHO WANT TO UNDERCUT
THE PRESIDENT.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> I DON’T KNOW WHERE THIS LEAK
CAME FROM, BUT WHEN PERIODICALS
REPORT THIS INFORMATION, IT
BREAKS MY HEART BECAUSE IT POKES
OUR INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS AND
OUR MILITARY WENT DOWN LIKE MEN
AND WOMEN AT RISK.
IT IS DANGEROUS, UNLAWFUL, AND I
HOPE WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHO DID
IT AND THEY’LL BE BROUGHT TO
JUSTICE.
>> Bret: YOU DID SPEAK THAT
IRAN WAS USING THE TALIBAN.
HE SPOKE OUT ABOUT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE AT THE
TIME, WHICH OBVIOUSLY YOU
CRITICIZED IN THE OVERALL DEAL.
>> YES, ABSOLUTE TRUTH.
I’VE SPOKEN ABOUT THE IRANIANS
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO THE
TALIBAN.
I’VE CRITICIZED OTHER
GOVERNMENTS, WE WORK TO MAKE
SURE PAKISTAN WAS IN PROVIDING
AID FOR THE TALIBAN IN
AFGHANISTAN TOO.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT
AMERICA’S WHEREVER THEY’RE
SERVING.
>> Bret: ONE, THE TALIBAN
PEACE DEAL, YOU SAID THEY WOULD
PUBLICLY RENOUNCE AL QAEDA.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT IN MARCH,
LISTEN.
>> WOULD NOT ALLOW ANY OF ITS
MEMBERS, INCLUDING AL QAEDA TO
USE THE SOIL OF AFGHANISTAN TO
THREATEN THE UNITED STATES AND
ITS ALLIES.
THAT’S NOT REALLY A BREAK.
THAT’S NOT REALLY RENOUNCING
AL QAEDA.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO LET THEM
OPERATE HERE.
DO YOU KNOW, BRETT.
I’VE DONE IT FOR 20 YEARS, NOT
CAN YOU LET THEM OPERATE
ANYMORE.
THAT’S A CENTRAL POSITION.
SPOONY WENT FURTHER SAYING THEY
WOULD EVENTUALLY TAKE UP ARMS
AND FIGHT AL QAEDA AND WORKING
ALONGSIDE US, HAVE YOU SEEN ANY
INDICATION THAT THE TALIBAN IS
DOING ANY OF THAT?
>> YES.
>> HOW?
>> I CAN’T TALK THE THINGS THAT
I’VE SEEN, BUT I’VE SPOKEN TO
THE TALIBAN THIS WEEK TO FURTHER
PEACE NEGOTIATIONS TO TRY TO GET
THEM TO THE TABLE WITH THE
AFGHANISTAN GOVERNMENT, I THINK
WE’RE CLOSER THAN WE WERE A
COUPLE WEEKS BACK.
THE TALIBAN CONTINUES TO PRESS
UPON THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BREAK FROM AL QAEDA, AND WE
THINK WE WILL BE ABLE TO SEE
WHEN WE GET TO THAT POINT, WHEN
WE HAVE THESE NEGOTIATIONS COME
IN, I THINK THE WORLD WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE THE TALIBAN ARE NOT
GOING TO TOLERATE WHAT THEY
PERMITTED TO HAPPEN.
THE PAKISTANIS TOO WOULD DO THE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE.
REMEMBER, WERE DOWN TO A COUPLE
100 ACTIVE AL QAEDA BUYERS
INSIDE OF AFGHANISTAN.
THE REASON WHY WE WENT THERE IN
2001 WAS TO CRUSH AL QAEDA.
THAT HAS BEEN ACHIEVED.
>> AMERICA WILL HAVE U.S. TROOPS
IN AFGHANISTAN ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY QUESTION MIKE >>
THE PRESIDENT WILL MAKE THAT
DECISION.
>> Bret: YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
IS THERE ANY PUSHBACK?
>> WERE NOT ALLOWING EUROPEANS
TO COME HERE TODAY EITHER,
BRETT.
RING CLOSE CONVERSATION WITH
COUNTRIES ALL AROUND THE WORLD,
INCLUDING EUROPE TO MAKE SURE WE
OPEN OUR COUNTRY TO TRAVEL FROM
THEIR NATION AND DO SO IN A WAY
THAT KEEPS PEOPLE SAFE AND
REDUCE RISK OF COVID-19.
I’M CONFIDENT WE WILL GET THIS
RIGHT.
WE NEED TO GET THIS RIGHT, WE
NEED TO GET THE ECONOMY OPEN AND
GET PEOPLE TRAVELING ALL ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES, AND
INTERNATIONALLY AS WELL.